you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
an environmentalist party has won
greenland's election
their opposition to a controversial rare
earth mine
will have big repercussions for the
future of green energy china opened
more new coal-fired power stations in
2020 than the rest of the world
shut down meaning the first global
increase in coal capacity
for five years and the kenyan engineer
who's found a solution
to nairobi's plastic problem
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions because while the climate
crisis is happening
we can slow it and that sentiment was
reflected in an exclusive poll
conducted for the launch of this show
most people were optimistic that climate
change was solvable
even if there were mixed views about who
was responsible so
68 of people said that the world could
limit the impact of climate change
if we make the right decisions well our
climate correspondent lisa holland is
here to tell us more lisa
well anna good news in that two-thirds
of people think that the climate
emergency can be halted
if we take the right actions as
individuals and as governments
as well but the polls show that
increasingly people think that it's
somebody else's problem
69 of those questioned said they felt
that they didn't
feel the impact of climate change within
their own communities
and there are still people who feel that
they don't want to make big changes to
their lifestyles to help tackle climate
change as well
23 percent of people questions said they
weren't prepared to make
a single key change now that's things
like paying more to fly abroad
or also switching for example from a
petrol and diesel car to an electric
vehicle however i do feel that over the
course of the last 12 months
we have seen a growing awareness of the
issues surrounding climate change and
that has been reflected in the poll as
well
more than 80 of people for example said
that they understood what we mean by
renewable energy so that's things like
wind and solar
more than 80 of people again also said
that they understand what we mean by
carbon footprint that's the amount of
emissions we all create in our own daily
lives however there wasn't a huge amount
of understanding of the term cop 26
now that's the landmark climate
conference which is going to be held
by the uk in glasgow at the end of the
year and we're definitely going to be
hearing a lot more about that
we are lisa thank you and if you're
unclear on any of those terms like net
zero or cop 26 just head to our website
skynews.com
climate for our a to z glossary
now a snap election in greenland has
exposed tensions between politics
business
mining and renewable technologies
today's result
a win by a left-wing environmentalist
party puts the future of big rare earth
mining projects there in doubt
now rare earth minerals are crucial to
reach emissions targets they're used in
everything from wind turbines to
electric cars
and even combat aircraft so here's where
they're found and the highest number of
reserves are in china with approximately
44
million tonnes second is vietnam
followed by brazil
but today all eyes were on greenland
where companies want to exploit the one
and a half million tonnes of
untapped minerals now the result of the
election casts
doubt on the mining complex here in the
south of the island which many
greenlanders oppose
because the minerals are notoriously
dirty to process
so here's all you need to know about
rare earth elements in 60 seconds
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our defense and security correspondent
alistair bunkel joins me now and
alastair it's not just greenland where
there are potential tensions over these
very precious resources is it
no it's not and it's not just mobile
phones electric cars perhaps in the
television that you're watching this on
that has been built using rare earth
minerals but
also vital military technology like the
f-35
fifth generation stealth fighter jets
like new submarines and
anti-missile devices and that is why
rare earth minerals have been
nicknamed industrial gold and it's why
they're so
vital to national security that the
recent british
integrated foreign policy and security
review
put them down as a global security issue
in the years to come why well as you
outlined because of
china china is dominant in the mining
and the production
of railroad rare earth minerals so much
so
that if there was a wider trade war
we've seen some of that between the u.s
and china already
or if there was a conflict between china
and the west then they could dominate
and cut off the supply line so that is
why britain
and others have been watching this
election of only 56 000 people
so closely alistair thank you
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and a big
increase in the number of
new coal-fired power stations in china
last year
cancelled out all the other closures
around the rest of the world
global energy monitor found that china
commissioned 38.4 gigawatts of new coal
plants in 2020
more than three-quarters of the global
total
several people have been arrested after
extinction rebellion activists broke
windows at the london headquarters of
barclays bank
the protesters say they want to expose
the banking system and its investment in
fossil fuels
berkeley says they're aiming to be a net
zero bank by 2050
and their financing portfolio is aligned
to the goals of the paris agreement
so-called chelsea tractors are living up
to their reputation
as a go-to choice for city drivers
75 of all suvs sold in the uk are
registered to people
living in towns and cities even though
they produce
more carbon emissions than other new
petrol cars
the british army is launching its first
solar farm in leckenfield
it's one of four sites being built at
the defence school of transport
as part of plans to increase renewable
energy together they'll reduce carbon
emissions by 2000
tons each year and a swedish car maker
has promised to build the world's
first carbon neutral electric car by
2030
without simply offsetting emissions
pulsar which is owned by
volvo says it will do this by cutting
emissions in its supply chain
rather than relying on carbon offsetting
measures like planting trees
we know that materials are at the root
of the the carbon footprint of a car
and how they are produced in terms of
the the energy used in the production if
there are direct emissions from the
processes for example
that will be key and climate cast takes
a more in-depth look at the climate
issues of the week
in our first episode we'll be looking at
how climate change is influencing
the weather and you can find that
wherever you normally get your podcast
from
so let's take a look now at some of the
changes happening to our planet right
now and here is our data
dashboard let's take a look at the top
of it first of all and this is our
real-time
power mix now this shows how much of the
energy in great britain
is being created from fossil fuels such
as oil and gas
renewable sources including wind solar
and hydroelectric
and also nuclear power and britain's
energy was actually the greenest it's
ever been this week at lunchtime on
easter monday and that's because of the
sunny spells and the blustery conditions
along with a low demand for power now
this
number shows how much our planet is
warming right now and it's ticking up
every second
in the 2015 paris agreement 196
countries around the world
agreed to work towards keeping global
warming below
two degrees ideally at around 1.5
degrees in order to avoid
the worst impacts of climate change and
this number is counting down
second by second as we head towards 1.5
degrees of warming
and lastly this is an up to the second
assessment of total global carbon
dioxide emissions around the world now
co2 emissions
are the biggest contributor to
human-induced climate change
so in order to keep that number at 1.5
degrees
this number is crucial and we're
watching these numbers every day
if you want to see them at any time do
just head to our website
skynews.com now kenyan engineer
zambi is one of many people coming up
with ways to help solve the climate
crisis
plastic not only poses an immense
pollution problem
it also exacerbates climate change from
fossil fuels needed in its production
to the emissions used to create it and
zambi was fed up seeing tons of plastic
waste piling up in nairobi
every day and decided to put it to
better use
hi my name is zambi zambi mate
and i'm the founder of djing makers
limited our first
product lineup heavens which are used
for sidewalks food parts and driveways
and i was reproduced using recycled with
plastic
a bunch of me and friends of mine came
together and we were just tired
the government is not doing enough the
stakeholders are not doing enough we as
a people we are not doing enough so we
started by collecting plastic waste
within our estate sorting them and
selling to recyclers
realize you're collecting more plastic
than we are selling to recyclers so that
made us think so what more can we do so
we decided why don't we
start making papers because that was a
first of all an easy entry to the market
and also the demand was high we started
in my mom's backyard
and my neighbors didn't like the process
that's when we moved to the industrial
part of nairobi and in 2020 we launched
the product officially in the market
let's turn trash into cash we land on
the job
the more we did the more we learned the
more we did the more we learned so and
we
hence become the masters of our own
skill
if you have a project if you have an
idea if you have a solution that you
feel that you can execute you can
you you can solve that problem just
start because the fear
the feel of the unknown tends to hold
you back in starting but
once you start it's home and dry
so yeah that's me so
[Music]
and a reminder that starting this friday
you can watch our digital weekly climate
show on sky news's social channels
as well as our app and website and
that's everything from us for today
on the daily climate show tomorrow how
mining cryptocurrency in china
could undermine the country's commitment
to be carbon neutral
by 2060. we've got exclusive access to a
bitcoin farm
we're in a bitcoin boom and this is the
frontier it is dirty
it is noisy it uses a lot of energy and
there are hundreds of gray sites like
this all across china
beyond the reach of the authorities the
question is what effect that could have
on the environment that's at the same
time tomorrow here on sky news
see you then